[Aplausos]
[Música]
os lanzó una pregunta os acordáis de la
epidemia del ébola que tuvo lugar entre
el 2014 y el 2016 apuesto a que sí ya
que se convirtió en el primer brote de
ébola en el que se produjeron contagios
locales fuera de áfrica hasta entonces
el ébola siempre había causado sus
estragos en el continente africano que
es precisamente de dónde procede este
virus
[Música]
y es que si el coronavirus nos parece ya
suficientemente letal como para tomarnos
lo muy pero que muy en serio la juega en
otra liga este virus de la familia de
los filo virus tiene una tasa de
letalidad entre el 60 y el 80 por ciento
de los pacientes contagiados es decir si
te infectas con ébola es muy probable
que no sobreviva para contarlo sin
embargo la ventaja que tiene por decirlo
de alguna forma es que no es tan
contagioso como el sars coronavirus 2
para infectarse hay que mantener un
contacto muy estrecho con los fluidos
del enfermo fluidos como por ejemplo el
sudor y eso es precisamente lo que hace
que los brotes de volante y 2 por el
número de casos nos parezcan poca cosa
al lado de las cifras que estamos viendo
con el coronavirus
sin embargo amigos al tratarse de un
virus tan peligroso un virus que puso en
riesgo la vida no sólo de los habitantes
de guinea libería y sierra leona sino
también de los misioneros y personal de
ongs por su peligrosidad varios países
entre ellos españa decidieron repatriar
a sus compatriotas que cayeron enfermos
de ébola para tratarlos mejor en el
primer mundo seguro que los que nos
estáis viendo desde españa lo recordáis
perfectamente
pues bien el caso es que por este motivo
por primera vez en décadas se pusieron a
prueba los protocolos de control de
enfermedades infecciosas peligrosas en
los países desarrollados fuera del
continente asiático es con mucha
diferencia donde más experiencia tienen
en el control de este tipo de
enfermedades
el caso es que varias entidades
estadounidenses y británicas tan
reputadas como el centro johns hopkins
para la seguridad sanitaria la
iniciativa de amenaza nuclear y la
unidad de inteligencia del grupo the
economist realizan cada año un estudio
sobre los países más y menos preparados
para hacer frente a epidemias y
pandemias para realizar este estudio se
cuenta con expertos de 13 países y se
analiza una serie de parámetros de
prevención detección respuesta rápida el
sistema sanitario riesgo ambiental y
cumplimiento de las normas
internacionales en materia de salud
pública en 195 países del mundo
[Música]
pues bien queréis conocer más sobre este
estudio y saber si la experiencia de lo
que estamos viviendo hoy en día con el
coronavirus corrobora el supuesto nivel
de preparación contra pandemias de cada
país pues atentos
[Música]
pandemias funcionan los índices fijaos
un momento en esta imagen esto que veis
ahora en vuestras pantallas es el
resultado del estudio del índice de
seguridad sanitaria global de 2019 del
que os hemos hablado hace un momento los
países en amarillo serían los más
preparados para hacer frente a epidemias
y pandemias los naranjas tendrían una
preparación media y los rojos serían los
más expuestos ahora bien a tenor de lo
que estamos viviendo con el sars
coronavirus 2 podemos decir que han
acertado con la predicción pues como
respuesta rápida fijaos un momento en
este otro mapa
en este mapa proporcionado por google
podéis ver la incidencia de las
infecciones por coronavirus en todos los
países del mundo y me ha puesto lo que
queráis a que vosotros también os habéis
dado cuenta de que el mapa anterior y
este no van digamos muy a la par
vamos que no hace falta ser un lince
ibérico' para darse cuenta de que varios
de los países supuestamente mejor
preparados para enfrentarse a pandemias
son en realidad los que peor incidencia
están teniendo en esta pandemia como por
ejemplo los eeuu reino unido o países
bajos entre otros no chirría
[Música]
y os adelantamos que a nosotros sí por
eso vamos a ir un pasito más allá y en
este vídeo haremos un pequeño repaso a
la respuesta de las actuaciones reales
de varios países para enfrentarse a esta
pandemia de coronavirus y ver si
realmente estaban tan preparados como
dicen
para eso vamos a escoger un país
considerado muy preparado y otro
medianamente preparado dos países además
muy próximos entre sí por el lado de los
más preparados en eeuu y por el lado de
preparación media méxico
pues venís con nosotros a este pequeño
viaje buscando las respuestas a esta
inquietante realidad pues vamos allá
[Música]
eeuu se quedó en las películas amigos
amigas de visual político escuchado un
momento estas declaraciones del
mismísimo presidente de los eeuu donald
trump courteney lingüista chinese gran
meter working wall street y que hacer
y ya lo veis tranquila va desde enero
hablando de una comunicación muy fluida
con china después en marzo cuando la
situación se descontroló en su país de
repente china se convirtió en un país
terriblemente pago con sus cifras ramal
del observo stein aviones suicidas
eréctil de su relación ayer es que en 4
knarvik jenssen people in their in water
es que claro de alguna manera atrás
tenía que maquillar su responsabilidad
toda esta historia
[Música]
porque lo cierto es que hasta el día 28
de marzo ojo el 28 de marzo donald trump
estuvo repitiendo una y otra y otra vez
que la cuarentena nueva york la ciudad
más golpeada por el coronavirus no era
necesaria tran dice que la cuarentena en
el área de nueva york no es necesaria y
claro vamos a ver como ya os contamos en
el caso de españa la falta de acción
tiene consecuencias
eeuu se ha convertido ya en el país
donde más duro está golpeando la
pandemia en el momento de preparar este
vídeo los eeuu registran ya más de medio
millón de contagios más de 20.000
víctimas mortales y el récord mundial de
fallecidos en un solo día
tan solo el estado de nueva york tiene
ya más casos que ningún otro país del
mundo incluso más que españa que ocupa
el segundo puesto mundial
ahora bien la pregunta que todos nos
estamos haciendo es cómo es esto posible
si se supone que eeuu es el país mejor
preparado del mundo para enfrentarse a
una pandemia como puede haberse
convertido en el mayor foco mundial de
la pandemia del coronavirus pues amigos
en esta historia hay varios factores a
tener muy en cuenta
por un lado tenemos el pasotismo del
presidente trans retrasando y retrasando
todo lo que pudo todas las medidas de
distanciamiento social y cuarentena que
otros países ya estaban aplicando
[Música]
y es que veréis todo apunta a que el
presidente de los eeuu optó por esta
estrategia consistente básicamente en
mirar para otro lado simple y llanamente
por una cuestión económica fijaos
con las elecciones presidenciales de
2020 a la vuelta de la esquina y con
varios años continuados de fuerte
crecimiento del pib descenso del
desempleo y subidas de la bolsa que
llevaron a los índices norteamericanos a
récords históricos lo último que quería
trump era romper esta tendencia meses
antes de la contienda electoral
digamos que los últimos resultados
económicos cosechados durante estos
últimos años iban a ser su carta de
presentación electoral obviando por
supuesto el gigantesco y descomunal
déficit de un billón un billón de
dólares que habían presupuestado ya para
este 2020
claro todos sabemos a lo que conduce una
cuarentena y la paralización completa de
un país o una subida radical del
desempleo la entrada en recesión
etcétera etcétera vamos todo un cóctel
explosivo sorpresa a capaz de reventar
cualquier previsión electoral las
demandas de desempleo crecen hasta los
17 millones en tres semanas mientras el
coronavirus destruye la economía ahora
bien ha sido la tardía reacción de la
administración trump el único motivo por
el que las cosas parece que pueden
llegar a desmadrarse a unas cotas no
vistas nunca antes en los eeuu
pues amigos no lo cierto es que no en
este caso el sistema sanitario
estadounidense está tenido también mucho
que ver especialmente entre las clases
más humildes sobre todo entre la
población negra y la población hispana
los afroamericanos se enfrentan a las
tasas más alarmantes de infección por
corona virus en algunos estados las
desigualdades del sistema de salud de
eeuu pone la lucha contra el coronavirus
en riesgo dice un experto el coronavirus
no discrimina no entiende de razas de lo
que sí entiende sin embargo es de
condiciones médicas crónicas las
condiciones más severas las vemos en
gente pobre negros y mestizos que
generalmente tienen una tasa
desproporcionada de ellas debido a los
sistemas de salud en este país
jerome adams director de salud de eeuu y
ya no se trata sólo de que la letalidad
de un virus durante una pandemia afecte
más a unos colectivos que a otros que es
algo grave ya de por si lo peor tal vez
es que la situación de exclusión
sanitaria que sufre una buena parte de
la población estadounidense se ha
convertido en un verdadero talón de
aquiles para la contención de pandemias
a nivel nacional
sí sí a ver pensando un momento si
tienes un trabajo mal pagado una familia
a la que alimentar una casa que pagar y
probablemente ni siquiera tenga seguro
de salud y de repente un día atendidas
para encontrar mal y a desarrollar
síntomas de coronavirus irías al
hospital
diría si tienes en cuenta que fácilmente
te pueden cobrar 10 mil 20 mil o 30 mil
dólares que no puedes pagar pues a ver
yo creo que lo más seguro es que
termines quedándote en casa o incluso
yendo al trabajo hasta que no puedas más
y por supuesto es que no eres solo tú
durante ese tiempo vas a estar
contagiando a gente y esparciendo el
virus entre tu familia amigos vecinos y
toda tu ciudad
por eso no es de extrañar que por
ejemplo en nueva york la ciudad más
golpeada por la pandemia la zona más
afectada con más contagios y más
víctimas sea precisamente el bronx una
de las zonas más deprimidas y que ya
duplica la tasa de infecciones de
manhattan
y la pregunta es realmente vosotros
pensáis que un país con un sistema de
salud que deja en la práctica sin
atención sanitaria a millones de
personas que terminan propagando la
enfermedad por no poder acceder a
atención sanitaria es el país más
preparado del mundo para enfrentarse a
una pandemia nosotros tenemos nuestras
dudas la verdad pero en cualquier caso
os animamos a que dejéis vuestras
opiniones abajo en los comentarios
y por cierto un apunte que os conozco
que el sistema sanitario de eeuu tengan
más agujeros que un queso gruyère no
quiere decir ni por un instante que esto
implique que cualquier modelo basado en
un sistema de gestión privada tenga los
mismos problemas para nada
precisamente hace muy poco tiempo os
contábamos como en la republica checa
las cosas son muy diferentes como
también lo son sin ir más lejos en
singapur un país de cuyo modelo
sanitario os hablamos hace tiempo aquí
en visual político os dejo el enlace en
la descripción
de hecho el gasto público per cápita en
sanidad de los eeuu el gasto público per
cápita supera con creces al de muchos
países europeos incluyendo españa sí sí
lo has escuchado bien atentos
[Música]
ahora bien dejemos eeuu por ahora porque
tener presente una cosa el tema de eeuu
es bastante más complejo así que
seguiremos hablando específicamente de
él en un próximo vídeo
[Música]
ahora ahora pasemos a echar un vistazo a
un país que el estudio que hemos
mencionado al principio de este vídeo
consideraba como de preparación media y
que situaba en el mapa con el mismo
color
ojo al mismo nivel que países como
alemania china españa o irlanda
si hablamos de méxico seguro que los
amigos que nos estáis viendo desde allí
ya sabéis más o menos lo que vamos a
contar pero es que la historia de méxico
con esta pandemia no tiene desperdicio
atentos
el escudo protector es común
el detente detente enemigo
que el corazón de jesús' está conmigo
[Música]
méxico- encomendarse a la estampita
amigos de visual político el gobierno de
andrés manuel lópez obrador es uno de
los que más tarde han reaccionado ante
esta pandemia en américa latina
el primer caso de coronavirus detectado
en el país norteamericano data del 28 de
febrero pero no fue hasta prácticamente
principios de abril cuando el gobierno
ha empezado a tomar algunas medidas
de hecho hasta hacen nuevo mucho tiempo
el propio presidente mexicano salía por
televisión diciendo cosas como estas el
escudo protector es la honestidad eso es
lo que protege el no permitir la
corrupción pero vamos a ver hablo de mi
vida que me estás contando que estás
vuelto cómico de repente es que parece
una broma pero una broma macabra
teniendo en cuenta el riesgo real que
existe
cuesta creer que bajo estas
circunstancias méxico haya obtenido
mejor puntuación en el estudio de
preparación para pandemias que países
como república checa hungría o polonia
que si han tenido una respuesta rápida y
efectiva para contener al coronavirus o
incluso que sitúe en puntuaciones muy
parecidas a las de austria e irlanda
conclusión mucho cuidado con los
rankings
a pesar de que méxico no es ni de lejos
uno de los países con más casos
confirmados con aproximadamente 4.000 en
el momento de preparar este vídeo las
autoridades sanitarias del país ya han
aceptado que están realizando apenas
tests y que la cifra real de contagios
podría ser al menos 8,2 veces mayor que
la oficial
ahora bien lo más importante no es cómo
va a golpear el coronavirus sino
analizar la reacción que han tenido las
autoridades porque si con una pandemia
que ha tumbado a países tan ricos como
italia o francia no tomas ninguna medida
cuando la vas a tomar
y no dejen de salir todavía estamos en
la primera fase ya nosotros yo les voy a
decir cuando no salga
pero bien cuál ha sido la estrategia
mexicana cómo ha sido la respuesta a
esta pandemia
pues bien la realidad es la respuesta
mexicana ha consistido fundamentalmente
en no hacer nada algo que ha sido
impulsado por el propio hugo lópez
gatell subsecretario de salud fijaos no
tienen un fundamento científico sólido
en toda la historia de las epidemias no
hay demostración científica alguna de
que estas medidas extremas pudieran
ayudar a disminuir el riesgo de
transmisión
hugo lópez gatell subsecretario de salud
de mexico en estas declaraciones de
mediados de marzo el subsecretario gatel
se refería así a medidas como el cierre
de empresas las cuarentenas el
distanciamiento social que tan eficaces
han demostrado en china y que parece que
también están funcionando en otros
países o españa o italia
puedo cerrar la escuela y esa medida
aplicada a 10 contra 990 es más efectiva
que si las hierro cuando es sólo uno
contra 999 y así sucesivamente sin
embargo a los pocos días ya a finales de
marzo los políticos mexicanos empezaron
a aceptar la realidad de lo que se les
podía venir encima eso si perdiendo un
precioso tiempo por el camino un caso
que recuerda desgraciadamente un poco al
de españa el gobierno de méxico declaró
emergencia sanitaria por coronavirus y
esta declaración de emergencia vino
acompañada de medidas como la suspensión
de todas las actividades no esenciales
incluidas las clases y también se pidió
a la población que se quedara en casa no
siendo sin embargo algo obligatorio como
por ejemplo si lo es en españa o en
italia
[Aplausos]
el problema es que hasta ahora méxico ha
perdido desde el primer caso detectado
la friolera de un mes y medio lo que
tampoco hace pensar que hayan funcionado
los mecanismos de prevención y respuesta
rápida en un país en el que ya se
reportan más de 500 casos diarios sin
hacer prácticamente pruebas
vamos que los del estudio del centro
johns hopkins para la seguridad
sanitaria la iniciativa de amenaza
nuclear y la unidad de inteligencia del
grupo the economist ya pueden revisar
sus parámetros de cara al próximo año no
sé quizás deberían añadir nuevas
variables el factor de la burocracia y
la inacción política podrían ser tal vez
algunos de ellos que me decís
ahora bien cuál está siendo la expansión
real de la pandemia en méxico cuántos
contagios habrá realmente
[Música]
todavía es pronto para saber esto lo
cierto es que teniendo en cuenta la
reacción del gobierno mexicano y los
números que ya están sobre la mesa las
cosas no pintan nada bien aquí amigos en
visual política estaremos sin duda muy
atentos de todo lo que pase en ese
querido país pero ahora turno para ti a
la vista de estos dos ejemplos el que se
supone que es el país más preparado del
mundo y uno de los que tienen
preparación media qué pensáis realmente
son tan diferentes las respuestas que
han tenido ambos países ante esta
pandemia creéis realmente ya la vista de
las noticias que estamos leyendo estos
días que eeuu es el país más preparado
del mundo para hacer frente a una
pandemia y todavía más importante como
consideráis que es la preparación de
vuestro país para hacer frente a un reto
de este tipo dejarnos por aquí abajo
vuestros comentarios y ya sabéis si este
vídeo os ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis darle al botón de like i
suscribiros al visual político un saludo
y hasta la próxima
word made in which changes gravemente
working cuál soy y qué hacer
[Música]